a top strategist for JP Morgan predicts
that Joe Biden will drop out of the 2024
race in March and I agree I believe uh
that there's a strong likelihood that
Joe Biden will drop out and it all makes
a lot of sense now when we were talking
about Nome this is last year we're like
nome's probably going to be the guy Joe
Biden drops out a bunch of people Super
Chat into the show saying it's too late
Tim they can't hold a primary now so
it's Biden or no one wrong this is the
perfect play Joe Biden stays in and then
through no fault of his own oh no a
medical issue oh he's having heart
murmurs or something he can drop out
then the DNC says well this is a
catastrophe for us I mean what do we do
it's too late to have a primary guest
will have to just appoint a nominee
sorry progressives no Bernie Sanders for
you no Jen yuger no RFK Jr it's gonna
have to be Gavin Newsome or Big Mike